they're already retiring angela merkel
at the wax works packing her off to go
hiking it's going to be weird yes
because it's now uh 16 years and
well
we we are we are not used to get along
without her but we'll see but you at
least you still have her here yeah we
will still have her here
after 16 years the leader germans call
mutti or mummy who's saying goodbye to a
grateful germany
while the world waits to see who will
replace her
the man who helped the green party write
its foreign policy isn't the only one
who thinks there's a huge amount at
stake well beyond germany
i think it's tremendously important not
just for germany for europe as a whole
we have a situation where we have a
change um in terms of the person who's
going to lead germany on the one hand
but also we have a totally changed
global
situation three
as a country's politicians jostle for
final position at another race in berlin
there is a sense of anxiety about what
happens next for germany
for both of us we are 23. um we only
know it we just know angela merkel and
so i think an era comes to an end
can anyone replace her do you think
not from the actual people we have
going for cancer no not at our we have
to wait another
period for the next election none of
these candidates can replace merkel no
not strong enough
no they are weak
hoping to fill merkel's huge shoes a
green lagging in the polls the liberals
the country's finance minister and her
party's candidates campaigning here with
her today
observers say none of them yet have what
it takes to replace her
they don't have the standing yet and it
will take them years to get there right
and and
it's also i think in many ways there are
decisions merkel didn't take they have
to take now whoever follows angela
merkel won't have long say analysts to
answer key questions about their
country's future
what's at stake really is what role
germany is going to play in the world
does germany want to be a real player on
the world stage
is this election going to answer that
question though do you think i think it
has to because the rest of the world is
going to force germany to make the
important decisions here about issues
like china about issues like what to do
with russia and so on um and it's just
it's just a matter of time before these
issues uh reach the boiling point
for all her skill at managing crises
angela merkel left plenty of unfinished
business making her an even tougher act
to follow whoever they end up molding to
replace her
dominic waghorn sky news berlin